real housewives of orange county is
shaking things up
while we seemingly won't see the og of
the oc vicky gumbelson
on our screens comes season 16 we will
see
fan favorite heather dubrow she's back
after exiting the series in 2017
[Applause]
[Music]
the former real housewife joins shannon
storms bedour gina kirschenheiter
and emily simpson and get this e.t can
confirm that one or two more women will
also join the cast meanwhile kelly dodd
bronwyn windham burke and elizabeth lynn
vargas will not return to the series
heather talked about her surprise return
with the housewives boss andy cohen
on her podcast i will tell you that i am
excited
i'm mildly terrified and i don't know i
i but i i don't know it just it seems so
surreal
it's so great i'm so excited and you
know it just is a testament
to kind of everything at the right time
i think the viewers want it the show is
at a crossroads right now
you know we we need to we have some
rebuilding to do
yeah heather who shares four children
with her husband terry
also revealed that her kids played a big
role in her decision to return
all these years later now
things are a little bit different right
things you know
my family's in a different place my kids
are a little bit
older the pandemic has sort of given me
a different perspective on things
right and then i started thinking about
okay how many times do you get to go
back and try something again
and as heather says hello again the
other ladies officially said goodbye to
the bravo series on social media
as hard as it is for my heart to hear
that i'm annoying
i agree elizabeth opened up about her
departure on instagram
writing in part despite filming during
covid and not really getting to know all
the ladies fully
this past year has been the most
extraordinary amazing and beautiful
experience of my life
she also changed her bio to covet season
survivor
as for kelly dodd she received a special
gift from her now former co-star
shannon thank you thank you shannon
fedor
thank you thank you thank you for giving
me my party gift
my love yep in true shannon fashion
she gifted kelly tequila we're gonna
drink this tonight
and shannon i love you so much thank you
kelly has been with the franchise since
season 11
which premiered in 2016. i just can't
believe how old is how fast it's been
going
it's crazy it's like you know i started
this
show you know at 39
it's it's bizarre yeah in a post-exit
tweet
the reality star shared her appreciation
for the bravo series
and teased what's next for her and
although bronwyn who joined the
housewives franchise in 2019 has
remained quiet on social media
she told the teen october that she
didn't trust her castmates
there isn't anyone on this cast i can
turn to when it comes to
you know how i feel i guess i'm sitting
here wondering
will you be back on the show um if
if i'm if they give me someone you know
i've said i need a person
you know i need someone a little more
liberal i need someone that's a little
more open-minded
it's hard to be judged all the time by
your cast for decisions you make that
don't really affect them
you know it's hard to be it is it's hard
the most recent season of real
housewives of orange county
left fans unimpressed this is one of
those things that you think is gonna
turn out okay
it got so much worse and in january
after fans begged for a recast culture
writer evan ross katz tweeted it was
time to cancel the series
housewife superfan megan mccain replied
in agreement
which is when the bravo boss hinted a
shake-up was on the horizon
you